in the in these Cycles
there's there are short-term cycles that
build up to create a long-term cycle so
uh for example we're used to uh what's
commonly called the business cycle or
the short-term debt cycle in which
there's a recession when economic
weaknesses is economic weakness and low
inflation and then the Central Bank
provides credit and that stimulates
activity and then you have the pickup
and the good time in the economy but
then it raises inflation and tightness
and so on and then that great type money
and then you go through the contraction
again and so on so since 1945 there have
been 12 and a half of those Cycles on
average they're about seven years long
give or take about three years
um so if you say okay where are we in
that cycle we're in the business cycle
we're about halfway through we're in the
part of the cycle where the tightening
of monetary policy to fight inflation
begins to cause the cracks and and
that's where we are okay now those add
up to a big cycle because
um debt Rises relative to incomes
through that because everybody wants to
hire up and so they just keep doing that
and so we have a lot of
debt assets and debt liabilities
um you know we think of there's there's
a debt that you owe but one man's debt
is another man's assets and so you have
to keep interest rates high enough that
it compensates States
for inflation for holding it because if
you don't nobody's going to then want to
land and you have a problem but you have
to have interest rates not so high that
they crack the economy and so when you
have debt a lot of debt assets and a lot
of debt app liabilities having that
Balancing Act is not easy and so because
we had the imbalance the central banks
of the world had to come in there and be
buyers they had to print money and buy
that debt to make a balance at an
acceptable interest rate